one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's father yep your pricks the barky
frown this is what we do
catch up for a few we'll riff and talk
some
[ __ ] and then we'll sleep till two
[Music]
hey here we are folks it's a hot one we
got a new pod name let's get her out of
the gate we [ __ ] up again
we [ __ ] up and it's not a big [ __ ] up
we didn't see it when we did the
original search
we've changed the name of this podcast
so many times yeah
it is now and the podcast isn't even on
the air anymore but i just don't want to
take another pod's name
so let's get this out of the way yeah no
longer fluctuates like oprah
all right that was a 90s joke uh
it really was you should have thrown
ricky lank under the bus while you're at
it holy [ __ ]
he sucks [ __ ] out of him all right
take that the people's court with ed
koch
by the way judge judy one of the richest
uh people in america unreal
uh so rich brooklyn jew i believe i
think so yeah
yeah yeah i don't know we're getting
like oh rip
yeah we'll get into that later we got it
we got a news segment but let's
out of the gate we are now called what
mark ah we are called
we might be drunk that's the new name
we might be drunk and i feel like it's
like a disclaimer
it lets us off the hook for what we
might say
exactly it's a cool t-shirt that like a
frat guy would wear at a party
we might be drunk you know it's a good
tumbler if you want to make
we need logos we need a new logo if you
want to send us logos just tweet at both
of us so we both see you or
i don't know is that is that the best
system mark what do you dm
i check all the dm's like a like a fat
chick so i
send them in uh i'll read them emails
well a guy is essentially a fat chick
we're desperate we're horny we're lonely
uh we're not hot but yeah uh so yeah
send them in and we are we changing the
email as well i assume let's just keep
the email for now
all right all right let's just keep it
good it's easier yeah it's one more
drink
with mark and saying is that it or sam
and mark
it's uh i'll double check all right
we'll figure that out later
yeah yeah i'm telling you we might be
drunk at gmail
it feels a lot easier but i don't wanna
let's well let's keep this for now we
will eventually change it okay but uh
yeah for now we're still one more drink
with mark and sam at gmail
we'll change that beautiful all right
now we got the housekeeping out of the
way how the hell are you i'm good man
how you doing
good good i think that's is don't tell
me is that the old bar
on uh 17th street
no oh wow great guesser you guess i
think your guess would be
peter mcmanus no no i think it's called
like
new york old new york bar old bar
no i'm rocking i'm rocking pj clark's
little
classic new york been here forever great
spot
cougar central by the way yeah oh yeah
was uh that was a
yeah that was like i was in the [ __ ] and
nom
yeah well
all right guys milfs the whole just rich
people in general go there
it's just a cool bar though it's just
like a classic great burgers
yeah i believe the original shut down
which is such a bummer it's in
everything it's in like
mad men woody allen would like go
it's like old school new york damn they
closed
i think the original did close i could
be wrong but
uh yeah bummer uh what
what's up with smith smith and
walinsky's i feel like i see that
everywhere
never been yeah it's kind of like a a
rip-off of pj clark i think
well it's a steakhouse right so it's i
feel like if it's a rip above anything
it's like
you know oh my god by the way some guy
[ __ ] tourists but i only read one
email and this one dude just like tore
us apart for
our assessment on uh phil spector and i
was like hey man
we said out of the gate we don't know
music and yeah how dare you
here here's another thing i'm going to
say we might be drunk
is per we don't know this is a free
podcast unless you're doing the patreon
and then it costs
but also don't get so [ __ ] worked up
this is this is an eavesdropping of two
dudes who are drunk at a bar that's what
this podcast is
exactly experts yeah that guy who wrote
an angry that guy needs one more drink
i know that's the old name but uh we
might be
drunk we're we're keeping the scene we
can keep the theme though it's still a
drinking podcast
yes yes and speaking of that what the
hell are you sipping on there
i got a little negron action
i need to get some new glasses here
great drink and a bad club
the classic uh classic drink uh
from italy oh italian drink
they love their campari in italy and i
believe it was made it was an americano
in the 40s a guy was drinking an
americano and he wanted to be stronger
so he replaced the club soda with gin
like it's it's such an alcoholic drink
that it was like
just get more alcohol in here and lose
club soda
it's like it's sweet vermouth campari
and gin it's like a total just like
grab everything in the bar i love you
right what the hell
is vermouth i i put in all kinds of
stuff i love a martini but i don't even
know what it is
well martini you go dry vermouth and
then uh
and then yeah like a negron or a
or a uh manhattan and people already
[ __ ] on me i'm seeing manhattan with
a d
with my dumb [ __ ] new york accent but
uh that's also sweet vermouth i don't i
think it's i have no idea it's like a is
it like a liqueur or something
i guess yeah i think it is a little core
but i've drank it
straight before and it's horrific but it
works when it's in stuff
yeah that's a good point i don't know
yeah i don't know what is an actor like
that
there's probably an actor who's horrible
on his own but you put him in something
and he's great
you know i have so many yeah i'm trying
to
i don't know christian slater well he's
fine on his own slider's good
he's a good run maybe maybe walken
everybody loves christopher walken but i
don't know if he can carry a movie he
can carry a movie walking can carry a
movie with the best of them dead zone
dead zone what is this what are you
going to blockbuster
i've heard that that movie since 84.
oh that was a good movie man wow
i've seen i saw it on usa once with the
with my dick in my hand
in a hotel in cincinnati dead zone
wow the saddest part of that story was
dead zone cincinnati or dick in my hand
probably the dick but uh let's see
he he kind of i think he was in suicide
no what was that movie dear hunter
yeah but he's here he's in uh
walking can handle [ __ ] i i get what
you're saying he is a cr
he crushes it as a supporting player
right
maybe favreau graydon swingers
but i don't know if he can hold a movie
on his shoulder now he's like a [ __ ]
now he's like the mandalorian director
he did iron man he's like
he's doing all right he's doing great i
love swingers i love it i love the whole
story behind that you know just a young
kid from queens trying to make it
and he uh he got doug lyman to direct it
great director oh yeah all right so i'm
going to
oh yeah what do you got oh sorry you got
the got the round ball
you know i've been mixing it up i had a
net i had a an eggnog whatever the hell
that was with bourbon then i had a
uh um what did i have an old-fashioned
uh so tonight i'm just going straight
down the pipe baby
oh mckellen 12. well done oh yeah i got
the look at that little cutie
god damn this [ __ ] you're you're
fading out like back to the future but
yeah we're gonna pour that puppy right
on top of that
round ice love love the mckellen man
clown oh yeah
classic i missed those at the cellar we
i think we talked about that when i had
one on
the show one of episode one or two back
when we were one more drink and we were
just kids with the dream
yeah yeah for the days
yeah man uh mckellen can't go wrong
scotch
oh and you do the round cube man oh
game changer it's got a just a little
bit of kick but it's still smooth it's
i think it's one of the most the most
tasty scotches i think
double double cask it's a classic
so what's what's going on with you man
how you been good i
just got back from oklahoma city and
it's one of those cities that we're
flying to is a
is a [ __ ] and a half it's like eight
layovers and
two changes and a you know baggage claim
and all that
it's a nightmare yeah how was the hotel
that's fine
dude i got a spring hill suites i like a
mediocre hotel i want middle of the road
yeah because the nice hotels you go to
four seasons
the wi-fi is eighteen dollars the brexit
million dollars
you know why right because they got it
on the wi-fi early i think they got in
like early
so then they were like they paid a lot
of money for whatever system they have
or something like weird
yeah it's free yeah exactly and you get
a free breakfast
and you know there's coffee in the lobby
you know you try to get a coffee at that
four seasons it's you know
1799 or whatever god don't you hate that
[ __ ]
hate it and it's too hip like i got 17
pillows with tassels on them and a big
bed frame i don't know i don't need all
that just give me a towel
and a tv and i'm good yeah now i'm with
you i
if i'm booking it myself i take a buy
out i am going to book a boutique hotel
just because i want i want a cool hotel
i want to see a new
i i'm sick of the chains but like if i'm
going to be in a chain
put me in like a best western with like
a good free breakfast and like
it's just down the middle i'm cool with
it i'm down with it
same same the the lady comes in she's
nice she's you know some kind of crazy
hispanic race and she's cool as [ __ ]
she's in there
you know what's going on not to get 280s
on you but what's going on with these uh
these uh housekeeping ladies like
they're knocking i'm going i'm good
i'm good and they just never hear they
want to come in and these airlines with
the peanuts i mean come on
i can't no i'm with you it is weird when
they're
they just knock on the door and you're
like i got the do not disturb sign on
what are we doing
and why i'm i'm giving you less work you
know yeah
they could get paid by the room is that
right i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i we need someone to fact
check this but i think that's why
they're so aggressive
about it all right well that would make
sense because they really
they're they're like they're on it
they're shoving it in it's too much
lay off uh chiquita i don't know that's
a black name
rosalita there we go i like that you
thought that made it less offensive
like let me just change it to another
race it's not me let me
well i got i got the hispanic part
[Laughter]
well yeah good to be back i'm glad we
just changed the name till we might be
drugs
i might have been drunk that's why i
said it exactly i was altered i was a
different person
but yeah great weekend great uh great
stick
great to be back though that i got up at
5 00 a.m to get the flight you don't get
home until
6 pm it's like a 12 hour travel day oh
my god that's brutal the layover now too
yeah that's horrible i i didn't do shows
this weekend i did do
a couple shows during the week just
running new stuff
but uh i tell you what i did do last
night i watched the fight oh
i just watched it unbelievable that was
i mean all the fights were pretty good
that guy uh chandler was pretty amazing
too but uh yeah
mcgregor fight you're like holy [ __ ] man
i'm not a big fight guy but i'm
maybe i'll get into it it's kind of fun
i mean that was a special case because
you know
regret they fought before mcgregor wiped
the floor with him i think in the first
round
and then yeah but it was like seven
years to go though no
it wasn't that long yeah yeah they were
both 25 and now they're both 32.
yeah 2014. i'm sure yeah pourier versus
mcgregor because they kept saying that
dude he also
um it's so funny poirier is like
the best guy you just hear him speed
yeah just like i just love this dude
every day
he was like and another thing like
anyone who like works it immediately
back to their foundation i'm like all
right he's a good dude
yes yes a good fight foundation he's
friends with theo vaughn he's from
louisiana
i love this guy like he uh i went to a
ufc fight with theo vaughn like five
years ago
and pourier was there and he won and he
got out of the
octagon and hugged theo and i was like
how big
are you i know you have a mullet but
like i didn't know you knew every
fighter this is insane crazy
yeah well it's also like it's funny when
certain guys like steve mayo church is
another one who i love that guy
i love that guy he but he also uh
is just like a bad [ __ ] but he's
like a volunteer firefighter i know
how like is it you're not likable enough
i met him once i have i have his [ __ ]
i have his phone number which is
what i did a scene with him on billions
and
and we spent the whole day together it
was dan soder's character
mafi was fighting that was the episode
and
what who are you you're a joker i don't
know who you are
well okay here's the thing we're it's
like soda's corner
brian koppelman and and david levine who
created billions are like
the coolest guys they make the show very
hip
obviously but like the corner for the
show is like
i forgot who was in uh the other guy's
corner but in sodas corner it was tim
ferriss
you know me who was just supposed to be
his burnout friend
and then he was the fighter and uh
you know i didn't really know him so i
was kind of just like shooting the [ __ ]
with him like he's i'm sure
he loved that i'm sure the fact that i
wasn't everyone else was like oh my god
i have a picture and i was just like oh
what's up man
yeah yeah so i'm sure that made it
easier but uh
he seems like a like a regular knock
around guy like
firefighter likes to drink beers and
watch football or whatever
and he's six five i think huge and so
[ __ ] cool
and uh wow yeah i ended up texting once
cause i was at hilarity so i think i
can't make it tonight but next time
he's a good guy though he responded oh
my god that's incredible
wow i would never use the balls to do
that but he was like tell me when you're
in cleveland i was like
yeah yeah yeah how cool is that
he was very cool i always assumed
because i used to watch him fight and
you go oh his name is stipe he's
croatian so i always assumed he was
from there because of his name and
everything because i never heard him
talk
and then i saw him on rogan he sounds
like a [ __ ] mook he's like hey what's
going on you know
it's just like a big beefcake yeah dude
and he uh
i didn't i got into him because he was
so cool i i'm just
i don't know a lot about fighting it's
not like i'm in a i'm in a basketball i
like baseball football i'm not really i
don't know a lot about fighting so i
kind of got into him
after because wow what a great guy let
me look him up i'm like oh he's like one
of the greatest fighters to ever play
that's i'm a dumb [ __ ] yeah i think he
literally is the heavyweight champion
right now he beat uh
we don't have to go too into it but uh
he beat this guy dc
who's also amazing and daniel cormier
and he beat him
because they fought twice well they
fought three times but
cormier beat him once and he's just a
great striker great boxer but then stipe
was like all right he might be better at
boxing than me so i have to figure out a
plan
and he went in with a plan and won he
just kept dodging his punches and
punching uh him in the liver
and it worked and eventually the guy
just crumbled and he beat the [ __ ] out
of him like
i love fighting i love smart fights like
that
yeah he was talking about it last night
it's hilarious by the way the guy who
hated us the phil spector guy is now
like
please never talk about fighting again
you [ __ ] idiot
no uh yeah i know it was uh it was
interesting to him talk about it he was
saying like miocic is in the best shape
of his life was very cool so
i'm i'm definitely gonna watch i'll
start watching this stuff it's fun
i need something great it's so
unpredictable that's the beauty of it i
mean i guess all sports are but like
i really thought i hate to say it i
thought conor was gonna take him
especially in the first round i felt
like he was dominating and then
fourier uh pulled out some [ __ ] leg
kicks and it was pretty great
that's what all the experts were saying
though like if if he
it favors conor in the first round but
then after that because
poirier's conditioning is so good that
it was you know
if it goes further it's all his so right
right yeah
it's crazy too like if you would have
bet on uh
pouring it you would have made so much
money too damn now you're [ __ ] now
what watches become degenerate gamblers
and that dude i always think about that
i'm like i watched basketball i'm like i
knew that was gonna happen i feel like i
should
i should but i don't yeah i just like it
so much that i don't need that i feel
like gambling
right the time is for people that like
need that extra thing and aren't as into
it i love it enough to just watch it
that's true i mean they literally say
let's make this interesting yeah
that's what they say when they bit so
artie lang used to have a great joke
about uh you want to make a football
game exciting
bet a thousand dollars in the giants
when you only have 500 in your account
man hey that guy lives i mean legend
legend yeah he's he's i'm he's
unbelievable he's so funny he's he's
probably the funniest guy
at a table to talk to yeah he can just
hang he can talk about anything and he's
interesting and captivating
coolest dude quick wit alien storyteller
yeah i love already i miss him i hope i
hope we see him at some point man
i know and his backstory is like
something out of a like a
you know like an old 50s uh like rebel
without a cause thing you know he used
to
he was like a pool hustler and he would
get into fist fights and he sold drugs
and all this [ __ ]
oh that was a story in his dad in his
book where his dad
you know would take him to the yankees
games and he was like when they won the
world series he was like all right
i can't go on the game on the field
after they win but
i can throw you on the field and then
say oh my god my son i have to get him
so he's like i'm gonna throw you on the
field
wow and he and it happened and they got
to like march the field with the yankees
that they won in the world series it's
kind of it was kind of touching
that's incredible man i i wish my dad
was like that but my dad wore a rumpled
suit and was a lawyer
and i'm like oh what a nerd now i'm kind
of glad he was that way
oh my god isn't that weird when you grow
up and you're like you're like oh man
you look at your friends growing up with
like eccentric weird parents you're like
i was my parent and then you're like
thank god yes thank god that wasn't the
case
i know i had a friend whose dad smoked
weed and drank like uh
like [ __ ] high life all day and he
wore a wife beater and he would like fix
the
fix the lawnmower you know outside i was
like wow what a cool dad and he's like
he hits me he hits my mom he's in jail
tomorrow
now i'm glad my dad's a [ __ ] dweeb
yeah
i used to have a bit about that the dad
who does you just smoke sweet with the
kids you're like this guy's awesome then
you go up be like
turns out he's a he's a grown man who
does drugs with children
so it turns out he's not turns out he's
not that cool
right right but it's so true you always
think that's the cool parent and then
you grow up
and are like yikes yeah
yeah and i used to go home and be like
oh dad you're such a nerd you know
you're doing your taxes
like a [ __ ] douche you know and
i was like yeah whatever you're doing
your taxes is such a good burn
and i was like you're on the grid you're
sucking up to the man
what about yeah whatever those parents
are like i'd rather
you do it here than out there and it's
kind of like let them do it out there
don't be responsible for a bunch of 12
year olds getting [ __ ] up
in your supervision that's almost
creepier i completely agree my dad was
like get out of my face go go outside go
go break some [ __ ] he did not want me
around yeah make it a challenge
you know what i mean don't make it don't
just like give him the keys to your
liquor cabinet at 12 and be like
knock yourself out yeah exactly go
explore
go [ __ ] around and do [ __ ] that that's
too
insular you know now you're drunk around
your mom
you know you got her in a headlock like
hey you put on weight good you know it
just it doesn't work it's not a good
it's not a good lifestyle but uh
yeah it's [ __ ] it's not a good
lifestyle at all what about uh
getting getting drunk around other
people's parents was awesome
yeah but on your own yeah i'm so
grateful like i remember
really thinking it was cool that i knew
kids who smoked weed with their parents
and now i'm like i can't even
imagine being high with my mom i think
it would be the worst
thing ever oh god that's a nightmare i'm
on edge around my mom
already if i was high i would be it'd be
a nightmare
yeah i just feel like it's like the last
person i want to get baked like i i love
my mom i just don't want to do drugs
but the kids who do like hard drugs with
their mom they're just like oh
[ __ ] yeah remember when you uh
realized that parents were just older
versions of you like
because you used to look at their
parents it was like another sector it
was like another group
you know and then you're like oh you're
just me
a few years later you're just me with a
mortgage
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] weird it's weird
it's weird because you kind of
i mean you used to have a great bit
about it about how you go these drunks
are just making it up as they go along
you know oh yeah right i mean story it's
so but it's
you know you you look at them with
reverence and
and you're like oh my god it's they're
so important and they're
they know they they know more than me
and then you grow up and you're like
they were faking it a little bit of
course of course and then your mom pulls
you
your dad's side like why'd you say that
i i said no to that you said yes
you're killing me here like these weird
power dynamics you know and you had no
idea all the behind the scenes stuff
one of my favorite lines in the sopranos
ever is after
they get into an argument with meadow i
think she wants to go to like spain and
do like a year abroad or something and
it's a whole fight and they're like what
do you do
like what do you oh no not even year
abroad she wants to take a year off
find herself one of those we were like
oh boy and and
they fight and she runs away and and
carmela turns to tony stick what are we
going to do when she realizes that we're
powerless
wow that's heavy that's [ __ ] great
that's a great line it's so
true that that nails it yeah like we
have friends now with little kids who
have to like discipline them and i'm
like
i've seen you do blow off a stripper's
ass and now you're like hey
ricky
being around kids i was with uh
salacious the other day our buddy and
we're just walking around he's with
charlie's little kid
and yeah you're walking i forget the
kids there so i'm like man do you hear
about that lunatic
at 110th street on the subway the other
night and he hits me and i'm like
he was giving out candy to everybody it
was crazy he just
he just kept handing out candy and he's
like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you heard about that knife-wielding
lunatic on the on the 110th street stop
who just was like
butt naked oh yeah crazy yeah
yeah ended up dying pulled someone
pulled someone onto the tracks another
guy jumps on to save that guy good
samaritan
and then the naked guy got burned by the
third rail
whoa but the other guys are okay
the other they yeah they had like they
went to the hospital but it wasn't
serious
wow i mean i know they're okay
i'm sure they're not gonna take the
subway for a while
wow man new york's back huh we're back
baby
every every news story i see is like you
know
i saw one where a squirrel was wielding
a knife did you see that one
a squirrel there's a squirrel in harlem
in some lady's backyard he's holding a
knife
this town is out of control
it is it's weird that we do get like
kind of happy because it's like
you know what it is craziness but i for
some reason i'm like
yeah it's like people are still here and
they're still dealing with the [ __ ]
and that kind of speaks to the
resilience of the city i
i don't know why it makes me happy but
like i do feel
like the people that stuck it out and
stuck around like
i kind of like all right you get a
little you get a little extra new york
uh honor yellow new york badge of honor
respect yeah
definitely especially all these uh these
brooklyn queefs i
see who [ __ ] and moan all day then then
now they have instagram videos of them
at their
parents beach house so like i'm getting
out of new york you know and i'm like i
thought you were this artist i thought
you were this struggling
you know starving artists and now i
realize oh you're [ __ ] loaded and
your parents live in connecticut
on the lake well it's also just like a
[ __ ]
it's like how is that good for your art
yeah yeah well they just don't want to
be uncomfortable running running away
from
from your life is not good for art
exactly
good point but they're i guess they're
like i live in a shoe box i have no
money anyway and now i can't work so i
got to leave but like
hey come on we stuck it out i think
pivoting is important right now and i
think you should
you know find ways to create despite
you know although so many people have a
podcast now they could probably do that
from wherever but
you know if you really want to be a
comic there's ways to get around this
i think yeah yeah you got to adapt you
gotta get creative you start a pod like
we did or you do a web series
or or put out a special on youtube
whatever it takes
you got to stay relevant gotta hustle
man yeah it's uh
it's such a [ __ ] weird time it's like
it's funny it's like i was doing like an
outdoor show and some guy drives by on
the sidewalk on like a dirt bike and i'm
like that's not legal then i was like
wait what i'm doing is not legal either
this is all illegal good point yeah it's
the wild west
and we're all in on it it's weird how
it's become normal you know
like everything is was crazy but now
it's all we talk about is vaccine we had
a crazy election there's [ __ ] people
rioting at the capitol like everything
just keeps one upping
not that that's normal but like
everything exactly is every
every conversation where you're like
it's funny when it's like
the people that are lining up how like
those words they were like ah they're
gonna go bad so
people show up at the end of the night
like they're [ __ ] muffins at
starbucks you're like can i have one
i gotta get that cronut they're running
out
oh i didn't know that you know people at
the end of the night were like there's
extra vaccines that
they're gonna have to throw them out so
yeah but then there's other places like
mount sinai
where they didn't get the vaccines in
but they took appointments and then they
ended up not getting the manager those
people even get vaccines so
it's a [ __ ] mess obviously but you
knew that was going to happen
yeah but you also got to be grateful you
know the polio vaccine took 14 years to
protect 14
damn and now we knocked it out like nine
months or eight months
it's pretty crazy yeah i think that what
was the record for a vaccine before this
is like
years it was it was yeah what like six
years or so i don't
i don't know so i don't know either
there was something it was a lot
somebody's pissed in the uh inbox phil
spector guy and another thing
yeah he's got a lab coat on don't don't
talk about vaccines if you don't okay we
won't talk about anything we don't know
anything does that make you happy
i know all right piece of [ __ ] yeah
people are upset i think it gives him a
personality he knows about phil spector
he cares about it and so if we [ __ ] it
up
we [ __ ] it i understand it i'm i'm i'm
[ __ ] around i've
been drinking we might be drunk
we might be drunk like this mcallen's
going down easy
the problem with these airplane bottles
is you i'm like about to kill a bottle
you know literally i'm about to finish a
bottle and it's bad for you mentally
it's also like a little badge of honor
where you're like yeah i spent it it's
like a short
story you're like i completed it you
know what i mean it's like
it's not a whole thing it's not as
intimidating so you almost you do more
yeah well i'll tell you this is a real
page turner i can't put it down
well i'm gonna i'm gonna go up i'm
switching drinks right now because i
brought one to my desk because i had a
feeling i want to keep going
so i'm gonna do a little light drink now
a little comparing soda
oh i do a little here's a little
samurail life hack here if you want to
know if you're a drinker
or if you just want to like show and you
don't want to get too [ __ ] up
you want a few of these sam's a heck for
live
so you put a little campari in there
lemon spin drift
the seltzer bam you got a nice little
drink
great those those little carbonated
things are just
made for cocktails it's the best the
best jerry
so good you're talking about being bad
around kids i
i have two nieces one is six and one is
two
and i am the worst uncle not the worst
the worst
i'm like a horrible uncle because
they're like marco they're like playing
with like showing me pictures they drew
and paintings and stuff i'm like yeah
how about that pretty good and i like
punch her in the shoulder
i can't connect it's it's a wall up it's
so
bad yeah can i bounce a bit off you're
like he's full right
yeah i'm like how about this fouchy dude
natto man has
the best uncle joke have you heard that
joke uh how's it go
where he goes you know if you're if
you're a bad dad that can mean a lot of
things right we don't know exactly what
i mean if you're a bad uncle
we know exactly what you did
perfect so concise i love it he's so
good at that he's his marriage joke i'm
so jealous of where he's
you know marriage if it was a car you'd
never buy it like how's this car running
well it's not easy bam nails in one word
not easy yeah and then turn is like but
then you hear about the new game of
thrones you gotta
you gotta do
check out his letterman dan aderman if
you if you haven't seen it
he's got an album and stuff uh also
check out uh andrew rivers young comic
funny guy
he's got a new youtube special give it a
give it a youtube search
check it out i've worked with him before
a good dude and a funny dude so
support and show some love yeah we're
all about the youtube specials baby i
mean uh
tyler fisher he's a funny guy yeah
another special
energetic different [ __ ] about snl they
missed out on that one he's
he's a talent ah mike cannon's got one
joe list giannis
so many people yeah yeah oh man uh so
yeah i mean so many i mean the list is
endless but uh but support
check it out and you know you could
always use more comedy that's the thing
it's like sometimes i'll just watch
something and like
laugh and you're like yeah you forget
how valuable that [ __ ] is man like
i know when you're having like a rough
day when you're down in the dumps you
watch just a [ __ ]
new funny thing it's [ __ ] great
i was watching this show this show uh
how to with john wilson have you seen
that oh
dude i wrecked that last week i couldn't
think of the name like yeah
something yeah i think you mentioned it
to me doing a text and then sound
accused mentioned it to me in a text so
i watched the first couple i love it i
love this guy
it's like documentary meets comedy means
is it real is it he's real he's a weirdo
he's
not a guy he's not feeding these people
with [ __ ] to say
some of it's almost like too perfect
well i'm like i i don't
i know the amount of footage this guy
has is uh south
told me a funny story read like an
article about him and he said like
uh the irs hit him up and they're like
you're writing everything off
this is crazy and he goes no i just
carry a camera around me i'm always
working literally and they're like you
can't just write off 24 hours or 12
hours of your day
you don't have a job and he's like no
this is what i do and they came to his
house and he showed them the stack of
zillions of tapes and they were like
okay okay he looked like a hoarder like
we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
so it works incredible man yeah i love
it it's
i mean you know what was brilliant about
the show to me is that like
it borders on making fun of these people
and then he has that moment with the end
at the end of the pilot where this young
he go
people that haven't seen it he just
documents everything yeah he ends up
going to cancun
to get a vacation but it's mtv spring
break
yeah it's a nightmare he's at the resort
and he's with this young kid who's like
seems like a bit much he's like wants to
be a rapper and he's like
my kid and he's like you're like all
right and then
he tells a story about his friend dying
and you realize that's why he's in
cancun
he's like why is this kid here alone is
he like a odd and then you're like oh
[ __ ]
like he does a good job of like
bordering on making fun of people but
then
showing that they're three-dimensional
and yes and it's kind of it's
it's a hard it's a hard line to walk and
he does it really well
he kind of it has warmth yes
and you realize he's long did you see
the one with the the the neighbor or his
landlord is that old
old polish lady oh my god
i'm loving it it's great it's warm it's
like you said it's got heart but it's
silly and a lot of visual gags and just
the footage he gets like
he's just filming a emt walking out with
a gurney and they dropped the body and
he's like oh [ __ ] and they put it back
and
that's just a random shot he got in
brooklyn somewhere
it's incredible it's incredible and he
uh yeah it's just so
funny yeah i i it's funny sound like
it's like i don't know if you'll like it
i'm like what am i [ __ ] made of stone
come on man i don't like when people are
like they recommend something
like i don't know if you'll like i love
it i don't know if you'll like it you're
like right i'm sorry am i not up to your
[ __ ] standard comedically
[ __ ]
well i i get what he's saying because
it's not exactly
comedy it's it's it's deeper it's like
kind of a comedy though
it's it's definitely funny but it's you
wouldn't go into it like it's a jim
carrey movie you know it's like uh
that's not all i like well i'm not
saying you i'm sorry
you know when someone's like do you like
i remember a guy once said this to me
watching this like
she's from like england or something
some comic and i was laughing really
hard she's really funny
forgot her name and uh years ago so many
years ago and the guy turns to me goes
oh i didn't think you would like her and
i'm like oh the [ __ ] does that mean i
feel like everyone who's like me
what makes you think i love myself
[Laughter]
well you know i don't know i just
i want to say this though the the dj guy
or the rapper guy
i remember being that kind of guy like
me too just lost you're going out to
uh florida to try to get laid and try to
make friends and you're getting drunk as
[ __ ] every night doing drugs
and you just want a connection and
you've got nothing it's like you're just
floating in space you got nothing to
hold on to
thank that's why comedy is such a
godsend for guys like us
well said yeah i feel the same way we
drank so hard when we were young
we were searching for that connection i
feel like there were like nights between
us when we were young comics
were we just [ __ ] like linked up and
talked for hours
you know we need a bar or whatever at a
club whatever we were but it's like that
[ __ ] is hard to find so if you yes
and you're searching for that [ __ ] it's
there you will find people
like you or that connect to you it is it
is a challenge though
you know oh yeah young and you're like i
feel like i'm not like these people
because that kid wasn't like those other
kids right right he was different he was
weirder he was
quirkier and they were like you know hot
dudes fist pumping
and like smoking hot girls in bikinis
and he thought like hey they're
cool i'll be cool i'm cool but they
don't accept it but he was in pain
too it's also interesting when you're
like in pain and you're trying to
to maybe internalize it by being like
i'll just go party and it's like well
that's not how pain works
right you get rid of pain by going to
cancun and
doing [ __ ] you know well send you a
frogs or whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
but when you're that young that's all
you know because i did that i was like
i'm bummed out i'm depressed i'm sad i'm
lonely
uh let's get shit-faced and you you know
the saddest guy
that you know just kept upping the
partying was like booze
weed pills coke then eventually heroin
yeah and then who knows and then you get
to methamphetamine and that's when you
become cool again so give it a shot guys
get in there it keeps you in line you
know it sobers you up
yeah before you know it you're repairing
the vacuum cleaner in the front lawn
but yeah it's uh it's a dark time like
i always i'm thankful for comedy just
because i have some thing to work
towards that i care about because i
think
that's one of the biggest keys to
happiness everybody's like you gotta
meditate and you gotta
you know whatever but i think it's
mostly finding a path
that fits you and just going towards it
yeah and just finding people that you
connect with like connecting is so hard
and it's funny like i feel like we can
enjoy alcohol more now
because we are connected like i i could
hang out with you without alcohol
but when you're young and i mean that's
why you drink on the first date
right yes you're not connected to that
person so you're like
this is a social lubricant let me let me
[ __ ] lube it up
right now yeah was with you know your
friends
you know guess what if you got to get
[ __ ] up with your friend all the time
that's not your friend that's your
drinking body it's a difference right
so like you're you're my you're my
friend who i drink with right
right right yes but we could do both
like
if you were going sober january or
whatever the hell it's called dry
january we could still hang but if you
want to get [ __ ] up i'll do that too
which is a good
place to be with a friend man people
that are sober that is a challenge i
really think about that all the time
like i think about going places sober
ah like that is i mean i like
i don't have a saying like i need to get
[ __ ] up i'm like having like a drink
or two
yeah like it's something to do but
showing up sober
those people deserve credit i don't know
how many sober listeners we have
but like shouts out to people that go to
things without a substance inside them
yeah
that [ __ ] ain't easy it ain't easy and
even holding a beer just having that
beer in your hand at the party or the
bar
that's a load off that takes off like 20
of the edge but [ __ ] been drinking it
just holding it
you go to the bar now i have something
to do i'll get i'll put the money down
i'll grab
hold here it's like holding a gun if
something goes wrong i got this here
yeah this will save me you know but yeah
it's uh it's tough and like you set a
first date without drinking like
how many silver people do we know that
are like i haven't been late in six
months i'm like what are you crazy like
i don't drink i don't know what to do no
it's tough
it's it's a challenge yeah
yeah but then some people come from like
alcoholic families and you kind of get
why they don't
so it's kind of like i've never tried
alcohol and you're like i get that like
i totally i've never tried cocaine and
that shocks people
me neither never tried it you've never
done coke i've never done coconuts
in common it looks fun
it you see the movies i i don't know it
just
i i don't like the idea of snorting
something
yeah i just don't you know i'll [ __ ]
i'll freebase it if you want to [ __ ]
send us some cocaine
no it doesn't look it doesn't look like
it's it's not what i want i knew a kid
who killed himself in new york city
because he did too much blow untreated
other problems too but he jumped out of
like a 30-story window and he [ __ ]
wait i didn't know he jumped i was doing
that that was a cocaine joke
[Laughter]
sorry i didn't know it was gonna go that
dark
so wait he did blow and then jumped he
just did a ton and
i i didn't get the courage to end it i
think that's what it was yeah
wow yeah yeah i had a two friends die of
heroin one was methadone
and he died od'd on it and one guy died
of heroin it's like
it was these were party animal guys
these are like fun guys and they were
bummed out
why do you call a heroin addict a party
animal
he's a [ __ ] party animal he just
passed out in a dumpster like yeah i
mean
it's a weird party i guess i don't know
right he's foaming at the mouth he's
twitching that guy he [ __ ] rages that
guy
parties well that's what they say when
they give you a coke
you party you party yeah i never liked
coke heads that was like the one
no cosby joke rory kirsch remember yes
i think you might have mentioned this in
the past episode but like what if
cocaine intensifies your personality
what if you're an [ __ ]
killer joke and yeah i mean it's like a
two-minute laugh break it's insane
yeah because he never cursed so it meant
more i guess
it's funny i remember i did a gig in uh
st louis once
uh i mean many times but this time was
like the valley park funny bone which is
no longer there
in between a gun shop and a bird store
so it's got all your needs laughs guns
birds whatever you're into
and i remember one of the shows i was
there for like five shows
and i had the same agent as mick foley
the wrestler man
and uh he said hey he's doing a show
there it's an extra show
would you want to host it and i was like
[ __ ] yeah i want to open for mankind are
you kidding me like
i loved mick foley like legit read his
book when i was a kid i loved
wow oh he was like such a lovable
wrestler i mean he was like the
he was like the tough guy who like he
took the worst beating of anybody
and he kind of reveled in it and uh of
course he was the sweetest guy in the
planet
but he followed me on stage by going man
that's sam
funny guy but he curses a lot that guy
well uh
i'm gonna give myself one curse i get
one curse a whole set
and he and he waited for it and he's not
a comic he's a storyteller but his
stories were fascinating
yeah and he turned to someone else he
goes you tell me when to do it the guy
pointed and he goes
[ __ ] he said [ __ ] the story and it
crushed oh there you go
there's something about that tension not
knowing when he's going to say [ __ ] and
knowing he's like a family type comedian
you know it's
funny that's pretty brilliant that that
way to set that up like that because
you're just kind of on edge like oh
when's it gonna come was it gonna happen
it was really good it was really good
also i love that that's the difference
between uh us and guys like him is
it's so funny how some people are so
puritanical or whatever the hell you
call that because
that guy will slam a dude's face with a
folding chair
and throw him off the top rope but he
won't say [ __ ]
well yeah he lost part of his ear in
[ __ ] barbed wire
from above wire match which is like
first off you should know something's
gonna go wrong when it's called a barbed
wire match i don't care if it's fake
you should know you're walking into a
[ __ ] show here i know those guys are all
booze bags and pill heads and they're
all [ __ ] beat up
think about how hard [ __ ] think how hard
we do the road and then think of pro
wrestlers who are
physically getting beaten up oh my god
dude the ric flair documentary the andre
the giant documentary it's all about who
get the most [ __ ] up i mean those
dudes were
[ __ ] wild look flare rules uh
he really does he [ __ ] rules that
guy's awesome
when i was a kid were you into wrestling
as a kid not really i
i liked it but i wasn't i didn't follow
it or anything i didn't i was so into
the guys
like bret hart and razor ramon and all
those like wwf
guys and like uh i mean they were just
they were so charismatic it was
like i loved sports and i loved
entertainment this is sports and
entertainment
right right yeah it's dramatic too like
you're going down
you know they they'd fight vince mcmahon
and he'd be pissed or whatever but stone
cold man
i liked that it was fake everybody's
like can you believe it's fake i'm like
yeah that's what's cool about it
this is a it's like a play with uh dudes
body slamming dudes it's like a play for
people that don't think the holocaust
happened
yeah exactly this is like macbeth if
you think evolution was a ruse
[Laughter]
no i love wrestling man i i really like
i
i loved all those guys sean michaels uh
so [ __ ] entertaining
yeah no it was definitely cool uh the
character
million dollar man ted dibiase and uh he
was a guy named
irs he was a villain he was just he was
ted dibiase guy irs he was like i just
[ __ ] i
i get your taxes everyone's like
oh if you think that guy was a jew i'm
flattered that was not a jew
you're a million-dollar man
yeah it's it's wild wrestling has really
like
kind of like progressed it's like crazy
female wrestlers and like uh there's
more diversity it's a whole new ballgame
it's great yeah i haven't seen it i
don't watch overland anymore because
like how many things can you watch
you gotta make choices but like yeah i
mean i growing up like
i loved macho man that was like my guy
he was [ __ ] funny that guy he was
funny oh
yeah it's [ __ ] gold man what about
give me give me a wreck like give me
what do you recommend this week
well i hate to be a hack but uh i gotta
push the tiger dock okay i'm gonna watch
it this weekend
oh man it's it's so good and uh they
don't really
you know a lot of these are just like
the scandal let's ruin this guy and it's
not about that it's like
really about like getting at the heart
of how [ __ ] up his childhood was
and how crazy of an athlete he was
which is cool they don't just like ruin
him obviously he did crazy [ __ ] and
horrible [ __ ] but
it's a lot about his father father son
dynamic right
exactly yeah but and now his son looks
like he's gonna be a great golfer
oh really yeah oh i didn't know that are
you into golf at all
i like to swing a a club but i don't i
don't play it
i'll do the driving range all day couple
are you guys oh dude
we gotta go out to chelsea piers i can't
bring it i can't do [ __ ] i'm not i'm
terrible at it are you
i'm terrible but it's fun i mean you
just hang you drink beers you get
[ __ ]
i would do that let's [ __ ] do that
it's super fun it's super laid back
but like doing uh the links i i'm
clueless
yeah no that's like a whole thing yeah
you gotta get a
cat that's how much work sucks they get
excited to take a day off and golf
i know i know yeah well you ever heard
that that great tom dries in joke
no what is it this joke's been morphed
into 18 different jokes
has been stolen but he had it in like
the 70s uh he's like oh man my wife
i came home one day she was naked she
was tied up to the bed she said do
whatever you want to me he said all
right i'm going to play golf
classic yeah do whatever you want i'm
going to play golf
to me yeah i ruined it
no he was the best wife jokes uh yeah
yeah he i
i messaged with him for a while on
facebook really
yeah because i just mes like i remember
reading that book uh i'm dying up here
and like what a stand he took and like
what a [ __ ] good dude he seemed to be
so i was just messing around like hey
man
really respect what you did and he was
so nice that we messaged back and forth
a bit
and he uh yeah yeah very cool guy was
like one of the first of that crew to
get on carson back in the 70s
he was sinatra's opener i mean come on
what about
stories yeah he actually you just remind
me i think he just sent me a message i
gotta respond to that guy so i gotta i
gotta
yeah yeah he's a cool dude he's a very
cool dude and uh
you know yeah he was like i think he
[ __ ] cleaned up on corporates back in
the day too oh yeah
yeah he's got to i mean just saying
sinatra's opener he's clean as a whistle
he's like
it's like a silver fox good looking guy
blazer
but a tough guy from chicago oh all
right
yeah yeah he's like a tough dude he's
got that great joke uh he's like
he's like ah my wife yeah she said she
loves me but she doesn't love me as much
as the dog
and the wife's like no i love you more
than a dog i trust me and he's like i
don't know i think the dog loves me more
and he's like hey how about this i'm
going to put you both in the trunk drive
around for an hour when i open the trunk
who's going to be happy to see me that's
great
that's [ __ ] strong i know that's a
great point you're like the dog's always
happy
[Laughter]
my one qualm is it's just the dog
doesn't remember
obviously your dog's got no memory but
it is a good joke hey folks
quick update we totally forgot we got an
ad our first official ad
for the podcast uh
you guys are gonna love it lucy nicotine
look we all got vices everybody's hooked
on something i don't care who you are
uh i got a friend who quit smoking now
he loves
nicotine gum he chews it every day and
look nicotine is not bad for you it's
just the smoking that gets you
so get on board this is good stuff
nicotine gum is a com
sorry lucy nicotine is a company founded
by caltech scientist to make a tobacco
alternative
that doesn't taste bad researched and
developed for three years
to be made for people not patience they
got winter green
cinnamon pomegranate and cherry ice
flavor losses
with pork chops baby that's the stuff
right there
pomegranate that's healthy
antioxidants right and everyone i talked
to about this stuff say it tastes good
too
so get on this stuff uh just for our
listeners go to lucy.co
that's lucy.co and use promo code drink
to get 20
off all products including gum or
lozenges lucy.co
promo code drink at checkout uh also
remember
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical but if
you go to lucy.co and be sure to use
that promo code drink
you'll get 20 off today yeah quit
smoking get healthier and get some gum
they mail it right to your house you get
a subscription
it comes right to your door each month
so simple
man i wish i had a booze that came to my
door every month
i wish i could smoke cigarettes just to
quit just to get this nicotine gone i'll
tell you that
you're here yeah get on it folks lucy
nicotine
promo code drink back to the show back
to our show
what about uh my wreck is obviously
how to with john wilson but i already
said that so my other wreck is uh
so i've been reading some of these short
stories before bed just to just to
[ __ ] sleep because i can't watch
i was watching the search party before
bed and it's getting so intense i'm like
i can't watch this before bed
right they can be too nervous it's heavy
it's fantastic but it's so heavy
so i've been reading some george
saunders on the wreck of my buddy ryan
hamilton
and uh so this
short story is being turned into a movie
coming out uh i think it's on netflix
coming out but it's called escape from
spider-head it's completely insane it's
great it takes place in the future it's
about uh
prisoners who are like they're either
prisoners or there are people that get
drugs tested on them all day those are
the other prisoners
and the drugs that get tested on it's
crazy it's it's also hilarious
but they get drugs tested on them all
day and
some of the drugs make you horny as [ __ ]
so you just [ __ ] something
like you and this woman in here and they
both take the drugs and they [ __ ] like
three times straight and while they're
[ __ ] in love
and then they take another thing to fall
out of love and then
they'll just test it so another woman
will come in and he'll [ __ ] her with the
same thing
and then they'll be like oh so now are
you still in love with her and he's like
i'm not i'm not in love with her anymore
after it comes down so like but in the
moment like i was in love with her
and that they're all prisoners and that
yeah and then i think this is called
molly
i've been there well so then he goes
into another room
and uh he's with a dude he's like a
weird dude
and then he gets called in he's like oh
they're doing the same thing with us
they are with the women we're just all
[ __ ] and this is crazy
and then there's a threat of this other
drug that makes you [ __ ] up so it's
like a hangover
times 20. you're just a mess the darkest
place
and they and they're like who would you
rather give this to of the women he's
like i feel nothing towards either of
them i feel
wow so it's like a weird thing but it
basically turns into a whole
uh mess and it's it's hilario
there's one line i want to give him too
much uh away too much but
you know they find out he finds out one
of the women he [ __ ] is in for she
murdered three people
and one of the lines was it was at that
point that i felt pretty bad about
[ __ ] and falling in love with her
but this is fiction obviously it's
fiction of course okay oh it's yeah
it's this guy george saunders she's
hilarious i think this piece was in the
new yorker
like 10 years ago it's super funny it's
really really
yeah yeah this this is a movie it's
coming out as a movie
what yeah yeah oh great yeah yeah it's
hilarious
it's it's funny and it's all so dark and
also kind of like poignant it's one of
those things where you read and you're
like
oh my god it's so awful they can
manipulate these people's feelings
and uh but then also it to me kind of
hit me because i'm like oh wow we're
living
through this dark pandemic so many of
these people are dealing with depression
and pain but like you know as comics
we're able to fuel that anger or
depression into bits at least
right and it's one of the things is like
even when i get low
i'm grateful that i feel and it's that
idea that you can like take away feeling
is so
[ __ ] up to me think about breakups you
think of depression and you're like
man that's horrible but then without
that [ __ ]
without being able to feel you can't
really connect yeah oh that's good point
that's great
so i i loved it i thought it was awesome
i think it's like check it out
it's on i think it's on the new yorker
website furry it's like just google
escape from spider-man it's not it's
like 40 pages or something it's not that
long or maybe even less yeah
but it's great it's great totally
recommend it give me the title again
escape from oh
all right boy that that reminds me of uh
uh oh what is it spotless mind sunshine
totally that totally made me think of it
yeah yeah um great movie
internal sunshine yeah i mean
having a breakup you're so sad you're so
miserable
and you're like i gotta get these
memories out of my head they're making
me sad
and they go okay sure here here we'll
come to this lab we'll do it
and then he's like wait i want these
it's better to have sad memories and no
memories and that's such a great point
do you think that's jim carrey's best
performance
oh that's a good question i think it's
the best movie by far
but uh yeah that is better than truman's
true right
yeah yeah i think so true is good but
it's a little
cheesy it's got a lot of cheese on it
like his name is truman
the guy is kristoff christ like it's all
it's it's a little too much
yeah uh but i agree that it's his best
movie
oh yeah but his best performance it's
either
i mean you got to give the masks in the
conversation right
oh the mask that's insane
i don't like the comedy performances
don't get love like i always thought
like it was a crime that eddie murphy
didn't get nominated for the nutty
professor
yes because what he did was insane
amazing he played eight roles they're
all hilarious they're all different
they're
all he commits to all of them and that
movie at heart i don't
it's like not a perfect movie but like
look
you know actors win for movies that
aren't great all the time it's about if
it's really about the performance
his performance was [ __ ] i think
eddie murphy and eddie professor is on
par
with like yeah yeah it's incredible it's
up there with like
you know some i don't want to say daniel
j lewis but like
that is harder in a lot of ways than
what what other these like
you know juilliard actors are doing
totally
i love daniel day-lewis but i'm just
saying like show some [ __ ] love to
yeah and dude jim carrey like the mask
is another example like look it's not a
[ __ ] great movie
but jim carrey is [ __ ] insane in it
unbelievable
and that was that was like his second
big movie at ace ventura then the mask
and he was still hungry i feel like
he was still you know a comic he was on
living color a little bit
but he needed it and he [ __ ] brought
the heat
it's funny it's i was just watching an
instagram thing about dana white from
ufc talking about conor mcgregor like
yeah man he's like he's got a mansion
he's got all the nice [ __ ] he wants
like it's like it's like it's like rocky
iii is what he said it's like
does he still want it like it's
interesting at a certain point it's like
if you're still great when you've got
all this [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] great aha good point
good point yeah i agree that's why you
know
bill burr is still great he's loaded
he's still great you know you got to
respect that and the best [ __ ] dude
too
yeah like david tell could could pack it
up but
you know what it is it's that inner
monologue of hatred that self-hatred
keeps you going
no matter how rich you get you can't buy
that off davidtel is the king
the king no one funnier
but in fact i want to say jim carrey man
on the moon
is one of the best performances i mean i
honestly never seen it
it's not a great move first of all it's
milo's foreman who did cuckoo's nest
so watch i love that i love i love me
lois foreman man yeah
amazing director who's nest is a
masterpiece well that's
yeah that's one of the best that's in
the top 10 maybe but
it's it's the story's not amazing but he
i was an andy kaufman fan growing up as
a kid and
he nails it so perfectly like you'd
watch them back to back
and you it would be hard to tell if you
didn't know their faces
and it's insane yeah i haven't seen the
movie but the clips i've seen
yeah i [ __ ] love jim carrey man like
how do you not love jim carrey
it's like it is to me like a sign that
you're losing a little bit when you
start painting
like like him and george w
bush and you're like oh boy that's great
that's a bit
isn't it great that's hilarious yeah i
mean it's like
i love jim carrey though i mean like
talk about our childhoods like
think about the 90s like harry and adam
sandler like
that was yeah if we're talking like big
comedy movie stars like i i love those
dudes
yeah i mean throw robin williams in the
mix like i would always think about uh
those guys on the couch at letterman
like if jim carrey was on letterman it
was like it was lights out he was going
to do
you know 18 impressions he was going to
flip over backwards he's wearing a
yellow blazer
i mean it was it was over i met robin
williams once at the
seller he was such a nice guy it was so
cool
um wow he's not what you expect he's a
soft-spoken quiet guy
i just for whatever reason i sat down
not thinking and i was like i looked
across i'm like that's [ __ ] robin
williams and i'm shy as hell because i
like any of us
you know mrs dad fire like yeah aladdin
aladdin
[ __ ] uh you know hunting everything
so we we just end up chatting like i'm
just what
yeah we talked for like 45 an hour like
something like that
and he could not be cooler he's such a
good told me this
i never told you this he could not have
been cooler we talked for like
yeah 45 to an hour we're talking about
life and love and like
he's telling me about his divorce it was
[ __ ] that's what i love about comics
he just came by the cellar not even to
go on just he's like i want to be around
comics
that's wow that's the type of duty was
so yeah we end up chatting for like
a while and heat yeah i remember asking
him like
he told me he's like man i lost so much
money to my last divorce like so much
money
and i said like oh man he goes yeah well
you know she earned it
and then he said uh good luck and i said
something like well like he's like well
this new one i think it'll be all right
and i was like
why did you keep getting married i just
said it like on a plane like why are you
getting married
and he goes you keep thinking it's gonna
be the one and i was like oh man it was
like so sincere it was like so
you know and we and we chat for a while
and i remember like as he got up at the
end we had this great talk about
everything comedy all this [ __ ] insane
he gets up and he just
tricks my hand he goes it was great to
meet you sam and like he said i was like
oh my god that's why like he's a star he
makes you feel so important in that
moment
wow i can't believe one talk with you
made him kill himself
it was crazy what's crazy was it was the
next day
oh man no he was so uh he was
amazing oh it's crazy dude and uh yeah
oh man [ __ ] i was a kid i [ __ ] loved
like peter pan and [ __ ] like everything
he did
yeah hook unbelievable all that [ __ ] was
great i i loved jack
you know flubber whatever it was i mean
he was uh
i don't know if jack was good either i
feel like now we're just getting like
way too cool
i saw jack in the theater i don't know
friend dresher was hot in it
yeah dude she's hot underrated hot
she's probably still hot i bet she is
he's probably getting all milfy and
probably has like some fake lips now or
something
[Laughter]
uh wait oh eddie murphy i wanted to say
this by eddie murphy
such a phenom such a talent obviously
like a living legend yadda yadda
but i don't think he should do stand-up
again
you know everybody's like he's coming
back he's got a new house that's still
happening
i don't know he talked about it on
communes and cars and it was he was
coming to the store every now and then
but like
i don't i think he should just you know
do it if you want eddie but
it's not going to live up to the hype
and doing it for the pay days is a
bummer
what's that it's i mean like dude mark
we're purists man so when like we hear
that
one of the biggest stars ever and one of
the greatest stand-ups ever
takes what 35 years off and then is
coming back for this insane paid day
like yeah it's going to bum us out a
little bit if he's not going to take it
as seriously as
we hope it's taken yeah yeah but
it's not even that i mean i don't even
think he's doing it for the payday i
think he's doing it because he's like
i'm i'm bored everybody's
like egging me didn't he's making a joke
about that in snl
he's got like eight or ten kids or
something and he's like a lot of money
all right well maybe you're right [ __ ]
well that's even sadder i was
but i get look hey if he needs the money
i guess [ __ ] it why not i get it we're
just purists man we just love
like i get do whatever you want but
stand up we hold for whatever reason so
holy
and and we love it so much so uh but
also yeah
i i totally hear what you're saying i
mean i
love i mean i look at i've rewatched
some of his movies during the pandemic
and that i grew up on like beverly hills
cop which
might be my favorite one i just love it
so much and coming to america
brilliant i mean he's incredible he's so
lovable
he's the best i mean he's the king
and he just got it like no one has more
it than him
but i'm just worried that he's going to
do uh
carnegie hall and michael che is going
to go and i'm like how was it he's going
to go yeah it was pretty rough
i can see that happening well
yeah i don't know man it's one of those
things that like stand up takes work
i think it does it's not like a great
way to put it
it's not like other things where you can
kind of just [ __ ] and like
i think it all takes work i think that's
why some of these movies when you
surround yourself with too many
yes men i do think the work tends to
suffer and we talk about like the price
of success like yeah you're rich
but the work will sometimes suffer when
you are
you know you surround yourself with
people that laugh at whatever you stay
and you end up putting out some shitty
movies you know
yes also of course the studios i'm sure
play a role in right
now like you've got i mean it's not like
eddie's not funny like everyone knows
he's like one of the funniest dudes
ever but like you gotta work at this
[ __ ]
you gotta work and you gotta fail and
him failing is devastating to people and
a lot of people don't get it you know
how many people do you know that go
i saw a stand-up twice in a month and he
did the same act
what a weirdo and you're like no that's
how it works you know but like you've
got a bomb to get
good material and i don't think i don't
think the world is ready for that
and that's that's a really great and
important point to remember that
what creates great comedy a lot of time
is failure and
failure with someone at that level is a
[ __ ] news story
exactly exactly and that's what's gonna
[ __ ] him up it's gonna [ __ ] his head up
i i hope he's strong enough to just push
through
and fail for a while and then well he's
not only strong enough is the point is
like
does he like it's if say eddie murphy
rolls into the seller and has a rocky
set as good as the seller security is
that [ __ ] could end up on page six i
know
and that's horrible and that's what
people don't get i mean they did
you know louie had the leak set that got
him in trouble and it's like yeah he
said horrible [ __ ] but
that was [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that was
like [ __ ] like
i even had to talk to my mom about that
my mom was like what do you think of
this and i was like
what do i think of them leaking an
unfinished set
yes i think it's terrible i think it's
disgusting i think like
i think we all make like it's also
it was an excuse for people to be mad at
louie because
yeah what it was was you're right they
were already angry with him
and this was just another story that
they got to pile on because
you loved when louie made those jokes
when you love louie
9 11 you just don't like louis now right
right it's not a story
it's a set that he did at a tiny club in
long island that got leaked
that's what it is yeah and and by the
way they're all it's so unfunny how
could he say i'm like well first of all
he's murdering
he's killing so you can't really say
it's not funny and second
you can't enjoy the old stuff without
this is the process this is part of it
you know interesting he didn't play the
game
he didn't play the path to redemption
cancellation game so he doesn't get to
make edgy jokes for what they say
anymore but that's kind of
that's the rules that have been set and
like you know i've talked to friends
about this
i always find that the the conversation
with cancellation
interesting because this is not like a
trial this is a guy who people have like
decided is gone
this is like another conversation
obviously but when people talk about
this
it's like all right but
you don't get to just make someone
disappear because you don't like them
yeah i mean that's not how it works i
mean like
we can have that conversation on how we
don't like what happened but we can also
say
you know you're not a jury
you're a [ __ ] dude with the twitter
egg so yeah you know what i mean like
it's another it's a bigger conversation
for another episode
well that well i hate when they go uh
hey it's not a canceling we're not
canceling people
it's it's the public deciding this guy
should not work anymore you're like well
the public
is coming out to his sold-out shows so
you you're saying you're the public but
the public is
paying millions of dollars of watches
internet specially put out
so who who's the public and who's not
you know
it's a game it's a game it's a game
that needs to be played and you know
it's
it's exhausting when you think about the
game you know like
yeah it's this is the beauty of the
tiger dock to bring it back to that he
they go through like everybody wanted
him to be the best he was the biggest we
all got behind him
and then you know the scandals happen we
love crashing down on we love seeing him
fail and we
pile on and then he redeems himself
again
and that's what the public really likes
is that like roller coaster of drama
you know it's his [ __ ] psyche that's
going through hell
well i hope louie gets that shot you
know i really do
and uh you know i think it was beautiful
with tiger i thought the
the the match where he he won that
incredible match lately
was was like a you know it's what people
love about sports and what people love
about entertainment
and you know that guy went through
[ __ ]
hell i mean it's like here's what i say
it's kind of like when you get detention
as a kid and your parents are like i'm
punishing you and you're like no the
detention's the punishment
it's kind of like it's like it's like
when like when they're like where
we're throwing you out and like dude my
wife left me
yeah yeah i lost my wife it [ __ ] up my
life like
it's a weird thing to me when i'm like
yeah the guy cheated on his wife
it's [ __ ] bad it's not good guess
what that's between him and his wife
yeah exactly that's not for us to be
like you're a shitty husband
right right you could say that but it's
not your [ __ ] business at the end of
the day
it's just no it's not and and we've all
done [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and no one just noticed it because
you weren't famous and you weren't on
the chopping block but we've all
we're all flawed we're all you just did
it you cheated on your wife
in a different way you cheated on your
taxes or you stole something or you
you know you ran over a kid and didn't
tell anybody you know like
so this is everybody's we've all run
over yeah
you know that kids shouldn't be around
you know
but yeah but no it's it makes me
it makes me a little annoyed people
people like to get on their little
[ __ ] soapbox they like to be
like well i've never done this and
you're like cool how many women knocked
on your hotel room door at [ __ ]
midnight [ __ ]
i'm not defending the guy i'm just
saying let's have a little compassion i
don't think we need to be more
accepting but we could be a little more
forgiving as a people yes
you know so let's let's all chill the
[ __ ] out uh i can't wait to watch it i
i'm not even a golf guy but i love
saying i love a good i love a good doc
and uh it's amazing and it's it's all
it's you know we work hard and like want
to be great at comedy and he's got the
same mentality
and yes great scene where he's up
against phil mickelson who's apparently
like this phenom golf guy
[ __ ] badass yeah he's awesome badass
guy apparently
and uh they both have some hard hit
like some difficult drive or whatever it
is i don't know the term
not a sports podcast yeah and phil does
good
and then tiger hits it and it goes
further but not that much further
and phil's like boy that was tough huh
man do you always hit that hard he goes
oh i usually hit harder that was a bad
one
and he's just like damn he's just trying
to get this guy's head he's
he's cutting this would be such a good
they should let us just drunkenly call
the next pga tour
that guy had a hard hit but another guy
hit it harder
the white guy was really upset the black
guy he was happy
yeah that's the most basic that's like
happy gilmore when he just turns to a
shooter goes somebody's closer
yeah exactly dude uh yeah i can't wait
to watch it uh
you know a movie i watched last night
that i've never seen that's a pretty
dope movie it's on
uh hbo max is have you ever seen sexy
beast with ben king
oh dude i love that's a stylized
badass fun movie it's too super todd
barry
for the last 14 times we hung out he's
like watch sexy beast
watch sexy beasts it's like his favorite
movie so i watched it last night really
yeah
it's a good it's a good movie it's a
great windstone kind of underrated i
think
i agree i agree and it's so cool looking
and weird and
you get sucked in and it gets your blood
pumping your anxiety's going
and he's so scary because he's such a
psycho of ben kingsley
so good such a good actor but it's also
90 minutes
shout out to a movie that can pull
things off and tell a tale
in a short amount of time because
somebody's done that
but yeah no completely good point every
movie now is two hours and ten minutes
yeah no it's tough it's uh you know
i i and look i'll watch a series see
some series will get greedy sometimes
like you rewatch sopranos and you're
like man
they didn't waste a [ __ ] scene man
and then you watch some of these shows
now where it's like
it takes four episodes to get in and
you're like and then yeah
yeah how's that like episode five's not
even that good you're like what are you
wasting my [ __ ] life now i know i
know it's weird
i i hate that especially now because
we're more add than ever
everything's two seconds and quick and
instagram and all that [ __ ] scrolling
but yet shows and movies are getting
longer you know like making a murder
could have been two episodes i know
that's five years old now but like
oh dude that was that one so long they
stretched that [ __ ] out
enough with that one that was i'm a big
i love true crime and that one was like
we get it yes he's an idiot all right
we got it he's a backwoods hillbilly 10
11 episodes meanwhile the jinx is six
the jinx is ten times more interesting
to me
ten times better that's a that's a work
of art by the way that jake that's my
that's my favorite one the drinks
that's pretty amazing uh the staircase
was another one that was huge
eight it was eight but that one earned
it that one [ __ ] earned it oh
i could have we could have got that in
four reps that one was [ __ ] that one
was [ __ ] brilliant dude look i
enjoyed it i love that lawyer guy rudy
he was killer but rachel rachel dm'd
with him for a while
what yeah because she's obsessed with
true crime rachel feinstein and our
buddy great comic
uh close friend yeah but she ends up uh
just following him on twitter and he
followed her back and she's like damning
him and he's telling her stuff about the
case like
that yeah and he was he was like could
have been cooler she said she was like
he was such a nice guy
and uh he was incredible dude no that
doc was [ __ ] brilliant it was awesome
beautifully shot yeah and he clearly did
it right
clearly all right all right oh my god uh
what guy who didn't do it is like yeah
follow me around
for 13 [ __ ] episodes yeah
yeah he's like an owl came in and hit
her in the head i'm like what
the owl theory yeah and then he had this
is the second wife that fell down the
stairs i'm like
at least mix it up what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah
your honor what about birds have we ever
thought about
if birds can do it exactly yeah
no it's complete insanity even in the
end i think it was like the last
[ __ ] scene of the of the whole series
when he goes
i got this alexa he goes which first off
i'm like you might not want something
listening to you because
your phone calls might be incriminating
second up then he just goes uh
alexa play leonard cohn and it was like
he's like this is my favorite and it was
like
everybody knows the deal is running i'm
like
are you [ __ ] kidding me ah
just come on everybody knows that you're
a [ __ ] murderer
that's like uh oj what's your favorite
movie so i married an axe murderer
oh but by the way you got a bit uh i do
we got to do a pet peeve too though but
yeah should we do a pee first or a bit
let's do a peeve
uh because i want to hear yours i got a
little one
that happened today okay people
who said people who oh you go first you
go first oh okay okay i feel like you're
gonna have a closer here so i don't have
[ __ ] i have like a mediocre
one mine's not great either but uh
in an uber it's five in the morning i'm
hungover i'm on two hours of sleep just
trying to get to the airport
and i had the chatty uber driver which
is fine i get it he's bored it's
boring but he's doing this one and i
[ __ ]
can't stand this where he would go like
he would yawn he yawned like twice to
throw he's like
sorry man i'm yawning a lot sorry about
that i'm like oh i don't care
and then he he rolled his window sorry i
rolled my window down i need a little
air sorry about that i'm like yeah
you're good
he put the radio on account it went like
a little loud sorry i was a little loud
sorry but i'm like
stop apologizing i hate the people keep
apologizing because you're like
this the apologizing is worse than the
than the things you did yeah
because then you got to keep going no
you're good you're good too many stories
too much no i think i think that's a
great point
and i it drives me nuts when people are
like
they don't do big the offense is not
matching the apology
yes exactly you're you're making me
blow you i gotta keep validating you yes
no it's okay i don't care because i
really didn't care i'm just
sitting back there five am i keep saying
[Laughter]
do you do that as like kind of like just
so you know i'm out of commission do you
do that move
no wow that's that's harsh i do that in
the car i put the sleeping mask on what
damn if it's 5 a.m is that harsh
i'm i'm it's i don't know it's like
we're not yet it's not my buddy on a
road trip we're [ __ ]
i'm on my way to the airport i'm half
awake why is that a big deal
i'll put the headphones in and go hey
man if i fall asleep don't take it
personal or something i'll throw a line
in or something to sleep
you take it you take it you go better
than i do here's a weird thing new york
uber drivers never speak to you in la
they talk better 99 of the time
yep yep i have no problem with it but
like when i'm [ __ ] half awake i gotta
if i'm up i'll talk but if it's five a.m
i ain't talking
i know the sun's not even out yet i got
half a boner i'm in pajamas you know and
this guy's like uh
oh man you see that uh that that news
story i'm like i don't know i don't care
okay
we got a 20 minute ride see that news
story by that uber driver who hacked up
his passenger
yeah exactly oh you know he's like where
are you from
i'm going to new york whoa new york city
big city boys
look at you yeah big cities [ __ ]
not me i always try to put it back on
that one like where are you from he's
like i'm from around here born and
raised and like ah [ __ ] that was a
mistake
because then he goes off on his life
story
i for the record couldn't give a [ __ ] if
we're talking during the day but when
it's 5 a.m
i'm sleeping in that car same that's
what i wanted to do but he just
he he just kept apologizing was driving
me nuts that morning shift is tough
that's kind of
i get it yeah i get it all right i got a
couple
first off people who say and i'm here
for it
and i'm here it's like by the way we
know you're here you have to announce
yourself
good point yeah never thought about that
oh so you know you're invisible that's
why you're [ __ ] announcing it
and i'm here okay we know you're [ __ ]
here
yeah shut the [ __ ] what's an example
give me a sentence use it in a sentence
like a spelling bee
oh uh [ __ ] blah blah blah
let me think like uh like the
negronis are half off at this bar and
i'm here for it like
oh yeah negroni's are half off and i'm
here for it
okay okay that's annoying yeah it's
annoying
that's brutal i got a bigger one now
this might even be all right all right
have you seen the new heineken
commercial with the father and son
playing uh cats in the cradle have you
seen that [ __ ] no
no oh my god it's like a first off it's
like a heineken zero ad where they're
like
playing cats in the crater the whole
time it's a father and son and they're
like we'll be together then
or no we'll have a good time then it's
like [ __ ] you heineken
whatever happened to hot women in
[ __ ] beer commercials like whatever
happened
yeah you're gonna make me like deal with
[ __ ] i've talked about in therapy during
a commercial
this is supposed to be escapist you know
what i mean right
right exactly well i guess it's
non-alcoholic so they gotta they gotta
hit the queefs of the of the group you
know
they gotta hit the the ladies i don't
know but that's it's too
emotional this is booze here you ever
give me a head club or a casino
dude who yeah you know who never made me
deal with [ __ ] that i've talked about in
therapy is bud light lime
shout out shout out to beer commercials
that don't make me deal with my trauma
right right you don't see that [ __ ] with
slits
and you know what you should that's a
[ __ ] that's a deadbeat dead drink
right there
right right you know that drink goes
well with tears
[Laughter]
my dad would drink schlitz hot he would
just keep a box on the floor like a no
you want and just drink one [ __ ] was the
paul newman and the [ __ ] verdict
nice well he wasn't he was a southern
lawyer he's losing his tie yeah he's got
the the sweat on the brows
that's [ __ ] gross oh yeah he was at
all he was a
scary man hit me with a bit
all right all right here we go now this
this could be horrible i thought of it
on the plane today
and it just kind of hit me as it could
be something so it's not worked
out in any way very wrong with mine
all right good ah [ __ ] my uh my notes
my notes just keep going hold on how do
you get to the bottom of notes on your
iphone quickly
i don't know i usually just search i'm
[ __ ] terrible oh that's smart okay
uh all right this is this is a little
harsh baby
to my lady but i think there could be a
bit here
um so she's dying to get married like
she's pushing it pretty hard
and i obviously i'm a child i'm scared
and
i'll probably you know i have an opener
where i
say uh i'll eventually pull the trigger
and kill myself
that's good but my point is she's like
well i want to i want to have a bond
like a legal bond so i know
this is serious and you're not going
anywhere i'm not going anywhere and i'm
like
yeah but how about you just be cool and
and and i'll keep you around
you know like why not just be fun you
got to earn it you can't just
oh oh now i've signed something that'll
just cause you to
to cut back and and lay low you know you
gotta
why not keep keep being fun keep being
like you
are and i'll still be there it's just
weird that we have to have a contract
instead of just
like what if i sign the contract then
you just change and and then start
slacking off
it's like what are you my agent you know
what i mean like it's
tough it is funny where it's like her
mind is like why can't we just have a
contract so we know we're cool and
you're like why can't we just not have a
contract so i know you're cool
exactly oh that's a good line
yeah like just keep being cool and i
won't go anywhere and neither will you
but
it's weird that it just feels like hey
i'm gonna once we sign this i can
i can become you know shitty
i don't want to contrary with
compatibility hilarious that that's
where your mind is at though too
it's like that should also be like an
added part where you're like you're so
scared to take it to the next level
because you're like she's just gonna
become bad
right right it's it's almost like
unionizing no i want you to be a good
employee and i'll be a good employee but
if i if we unionize then you can just
start slacking off and go hey
i'd say i'm in union that's [ __ ] good
dude
oh is that something i think that's i
think it's funny that that's how little
trust
you have in her to like stay cool you're
like
well if i get you a ring it will become
shitty right right
yeah you'll take you get time off and
[ __ ] i don't know
i it might be too mean that i'm making
it like a job parallel
i think you can pull it off i think you
can thread the needle here but uh
yeah i mean you are coming off like kind
of a dick here i think but i do think
it's okay if the joke is funny enough
right right like okay uh you know uh
the idea that she's like i want to make
sure you're serious about me
and she needs a ring for that but you're
like yeah
well i think there are other ways you
have to show like well there's other
ways i show i'm serious is by you know
uh
like what other ways are you sure you're
serious right now we live together
we we we're we sleep in the same bed
every night we do things
we go on trips we love each other yadda
yadda i mean
it's all there it just doesn't have the
little on a piece of paper
and a courthouse that's so funny it's
like she needs
the document yes exactly you
it's like supposed to be a romantic but
it feels like you're giving up
right you know what it feels like it
feels like i got the car on the lot
and it's great it's running great and
right when i pull off the lot and sign
the paper the bumper falls off
but i don't know i'm gonna ask you a
question now that maybe uh
our mutual therapist would ask you oh
god why are you assuming the second you
sign the paper
that the the bumper's gonna fall off
because now she has
she's got me by the by the the the short
and curlies you know it's legal now so
she's like aha
ah you can't get out of the mask it's
gonna come off she's gonna gain 10
pounds
yeah it's going to be over
that's the best [ __ ] you need to add
this part
[Laughter]
the best part is that you're like what's
your biggest fear
she's going to gain 10 pounds should
have said 50.
she could gain 10 pounds i mean to me
it's so [ __ ] funny
but i mean i hear what you're saying
like it is a power shift it is like
right
you want you right now you have the
power because she
you have something she wants if you give
that up
you've lost the power i get right right
it's kind of like if you're renting and
the toilet breaks they fix it
if you own the house you got to fix the
toilet
maybe that's a stretch but no i don't
think it's a stretch it's interesting
it's like
this is now we have to fix this now now
it's on me so you think of yourself
it's funny so you think of her as the
house
yes and if you're renting you can get
out
but if you buy if you buy it's a little
more complicated
exactly maybe that's an angle that's a
comparison yeah
if you buy you either got it you either
gotta [ __ ] just abandon
you gotta hope some other guys
interested
[Laughter]
yeah you deal with it oh that's great
that's great there's something there i
mean the premise is [ __ ] funny it's
funny because it comes from kind of a
[ __ ]
like it comes to a place that like
you're a little upset
to be you feel trapped but also you do
feel a little bad that you feel trapped
yes of course of course i mean zillions
of people have gotten married over
history and had a great time and happy
and all that so i'm obviously playing it
up but
my whole thing is like if you're just
it's kind of like a restaurant
saying oh you have to eat here now so we
can slack off on the quality
but if the restaurant is just constantly
good we'll just keep coming back
that's right it's almost like saying now
you have to eat here and you're like
whereas
you know exactly if you choose to eat
there it's almost like oh this this will
be good there's still
you want the restaurant to still bring
it you still want to prove it to you
and you associate marriage man women are
just [ __ ]
kind of better in certain ways because
they just assume they they kind of don't
care they just want to make sure they're
taken care of
exactly whereas men were like you gotta
[ __ ] still do this and this
and this it is interesting i mean
there's a lot there there's so much
there i think
they're smart in that way i mean they're
great negotiators obviously i mean you
argue with a lady and it's tough to win
they they know what they're doing
they're clever and they have to cover
their ass i don't even blame her
because you know uh it's not like they
can beat us up or anything
so they got to cover their ass someway
by the way side side tag you said don't
gain 10 pounds is funny
what if you say it's it's romantic to
say don't change
i love you with ar don't change that's
what it is
to say don't don't don't get 10 pounds i
[ __ ] love that
right all right i tried to do a bit the
other night it's not like a finished bit
or anything but the idea of like how
people say it's got a big heart
that's a compliment but that's one of
the only organs that's like a good thing
he's like rare like you got to meet this
guy he's got an enlarged prostate
this guy's [ __ ] awesome oh that's
nice
there's something there all right let me
try something about this this is
interesting i have this whole thing
about like young people i've
been like a lot of [ __ ] now about being
young and and coming of age bits and
i mean that's kind of where you go and
you're burning a ton of material but i
have a lot of i think some funny stories
now in the act about it
but i have one thing about hearing
younger people talk about i saw uh how
young people just throw out compliments
so easily now
everything's the the self-esteem now is
insane
the praising seems non-stop with young
people i saw
a kid he like a water bottle but it was
filled with vodka and he'd explain to
his friend i ever heard this he goes
well you know they're both clear so uh
you know i was able to sneak vodka in
this water bottle and his friend goes
genius genius like
what i think the word you're looking for
is frugal i don't think
genius is the word like what are you
gonna do
it may be stealthy i don't [ __ ] know
but yeah what are you gonna do
when some genius [ __ ] actually happens
you're like we found a cure for cancer
they're like
nice do you know what i mean all right
right i don't know what the right that's
not the right punch line but you know
what i'm talking about with it like yeah
no i like that
it's like we're upping the words too
we're blowing our load on words
exactly we're blowing our load too
soon and it's like yeah i just think
certain [ __ ] just is not everything's
great
if if you not everything has to be great
enjoy the mediocre
yeah don't praise everything that's not
genius with the vodka that's a high five
more like nice well done
good honey yeah that's a nice moment
yeah exactly that's nice but you're
right
you can't go too far because then when
the real thing happens it's the same
with love it's like when these
relationships they date for a week and
they go i love you
you're like yeah but now you're just
taking the the the the
the teeth out of love that's a heavy
word
you know that's also gonna be funny too
is like as a young person that's genius
as an adult you do that [ __ ] they're
like what's wrong with you just buy a
drink you don't you can't afford one
drink
that's true that's true i remember
making that switch with people like i
just stole a bunch of wings off that
table and my friend's like i could buy
you wings
i me i remember i used to roll with like
like the dasani bottle full of whiskey
too that was an area
same same that's true blowing your load
on words is
there's a lot there we do that with
everything
well we do it with language like we have
no respect for language anymore
yeah i mean seinfeld's got that bit
about like everything's great
and everything sucks there's not much in
the middle uh
and then louie's got that bit of like
hilarious
no hilarious is when you fall over you
know trembling from laughter
you didn't even laugh at that joke
i remember that special that was a good
special great special it's called
hilarious yeah
uh he might there might be something
where he goes brilliant
or something well the british do that
there's maybe a connection there that
others say
brilliant for whatever and it's like
it's not [ __ ] brilliant
right right they just say brilliant like
cool it's funny how the british are
loose with everything the british people
say [ __ ] like it's nothing they'll say
brilliant like it's nothing also weird
that the british just throw around
bloody
that's a bloody good show you're like
jesus christ
that's that's a little dark
yeah it's a bloody good show
americans say bloody we [ __ ] killed
somebody yeah we mean it
that's a period or a murder or something
it's not just a
bloody good meal oh
there's something here i don't know i
don't i don't have a turn on this yet
but i'll find it
yeah yeah no that's interesting you
can't blow your load on words because
yeah what are you gonna do when
something crazy happens
we do it with insane too oh man that
movie was insane
like no insane is when you have to be
putting a straight jacket in a padded
room
you know that was a that was a movie
with a lot of explosions you're right
the
the premise is like there's no respect
for language anymore
yeah there's no respect for meaning and
it's like
i don't know where i'm going yet but
there's something here i'll i'll crack
this [ __ ]
i think we do it with kind of everything
because you have to be heard now
there's so much that's what it is
there's so much [ __ ] out there so much
content
youtube and and and social media that
you have to be like
i was outraged like were you outraged or
were you just kind of like
annoyed or something you know you have
to go you have to go all in
on words yeah it's a great it's a great
point and it's almost like headlines
like the way we use headlines on like
twitter where it's like
this person did this and he was kind of
like they didn't really do that
right right exactly stabbing on 23rd
you're like no the guy had a knife but
nobody got stab you know
they always up it because they got to
sell papers
yeah i'll play with this there's
something here can we do a news story
real quick
yeah yeah i like that there's something
there here's the news
i got i got it two quick ones we got we
got it like
and i think it's a good thing we got to
shout out obviously the great larry king
who passed away
oh yeah all right legend
i mean dude first off i for whatever
reason i rewatched his brando interview
over the summer and like wow it's so
funny
like brandon was so [ __ ] funny too
but yeah larry king was
was great at what he did shouts out
eight yeah
eight times married to seven women
unbelievable
see see they all slacked off so you had
to get out
all right i'm joking but
yeah i loved him um he was great yeah i
tweeted the one time i wish piers morgan
replaced larry king
that's great wow that's a good that's a
good joke
um and i gotta also shout out i'm a
baseball guy so
hank aaron dine man oh yeah the home run
champ in my mind i know barry bonds
passed him but like
clearly cheated and like i love barry
bonds as a player too but like
hank aaron was the [ __ ] dude started
playing in the late 50s
like the racism this dude dealt with
when he passed
record like had to worry for his [ __ ]
wife and kids like can you imagine
being that good at baseball and you
can't even enjoy
passing babe ruth's record like [ __ ]
there's a great article in the new york
times about him today
where um the last line was incredible
it's a long piece it was so good
and the last one says hank aaron a quote
i never wanted them to forget babe ruth
i just wanted them to remember henry
aaron
incredible guy wow i've seen him
interviewed
it was a great interview a-rod he's on
baseball
on espn he's on the uh whatever baseball
night whatever and uh a-rod is
interviewing him and it's such a great
interview
like the reverence that a-rod just spoke
to him with and
and just the respect was just so cool
like a-rod just marvel like he was like
looking at his hands he was like this
guy's got huge hands
and huge arrests he was so he'd the
quickest swing
so uh shouts out to the great henry
aaron hank aaron
hammer and hank yes good shout out
incredible guy 86 i think or 85
86 i believe yeah he was such a [ __ ]
badass so and if you see him speak you
just like you just love the guy
instantly
just a classy man no i listen i saw you
post a few things i watched them all
just a humble
good dude and like got death threats and
all that [ __ ] and just rolled with it
never seemed he was like stoic
yeah he was a cool dude and just one of
the greatest
baseball players ever still leads the
mlb i believe in total bases and rbis
and he's got like 3 700 hits which is
third which is
insane when you think about 3 700
something yes
he's behind like pete rose than someone
else i forgot who but uh
wow insane and that's no roids
no roids man beast uh it's so funny that
he played for the braves dude they were
like talking about the the racism he
dealt with and uh
you know
so funny he's like why it's a different
racism i guess i don't know but oh that
could be a bit
that's funny
uh man wow that it's gonna be hard to
follow that that whole little uh
remembrance there that
because i got the worst news story of
all time hit me
and it's a horrible joke and i'm ashamed
of it because yours was killer
uh gwyneth paltrow's vagina candle
explodes in uk woman's home
and i all i all my joke was boy that's
the big wick energy
oh that's good well it's like wordplay
but it's fun
yeah it's a tweet it's a tweet i did a
bit on spade show
uh lights out when that was on i had a
bit about like
when chris martin was like still trying
to talk to her something i was like man
how good is this woman's vagina that he
still wants to talk to her after she
treated him and then i and i got the
candle and i was like
it's pretty good that's great
it got a groan i said it at first and
then it hit and spayed when uh he goes
you gotta let him finish folks and i got
like an extra laugh i was like that's
nice when spay comes in and tags your
joke
what does it smell like did you really
get one no
it's a joke oh okay it smells like a
vagina apparently i know but i mean
what the hell is that flesh is that fish
is that
what are we talking here i'll tell you
i'm not about to drop the money she
wants to find out
they sold out in like record time
apparently i mean
yeah it's [ __ ] weird weird [ __ ] sells
i guess
yeah i guess so yeah like those bernie
sweaters sold out in 10 seconds and he
gave it all to charity pretty bad ass
oh he's [ __ ] he's a character man
like he's like
he really is like it's like almost like
a tail meets larry david that like level
of curmudgeon right
right right yeah it's so funny what goes
viral like you can never predict it
he's trying to be president he's trying
to do this and make moves and nobody
really gave a [ __ ] then he's got two
mittens on and a folding chair and
everybody's like
we love it so true
well we should also say remember to
subscribe to
patreon.com one more drink pod we're
still under that right now we'll let you
know if that changes
yeah we were about to drop two episodes
this week one's going to be completely
free the other one's going to be patreon
that's a bonus
both bonuseps and uh make sure to email
us
at least temporarily one more drink with
mark and sam gmail.com
and uh and rate us on
apple spotify wherever you get this [ __ ]
oh yeah
tell a friend share it spread the love
we're all over the apple the spotify
we're on youtube so yeah
get on board i'm loving sorry about the
name to change
we're sorry we might be drunk that's the
new name i'm loving it we're just going
to call this we might be drinking
episode 7 though we're just going to
roll with it
keep going [ __ ] we've changed names
more than frank abignale
all right that's a hell of a deep pull
there yeah
we've changed names more times than
elliott paige i'll tell you
that it's only one change you're all
right i'll tell you
okay
[Laughter]
thanks for listening guys we appreciate
you god love you
take care bye